E aí
[Música]
e hoje eu trouxe um tema muito
importante no mundo e principalmente no
Brasil a preservação da Amazônia e
alimentação no mundo vamos começar a
primeiro conhecido nosso terreno o
Brasil hoje é uma potência agrícola
Mundial responsável pela alimentação de
mais de 800 milhões de pessoas em 160
países ou seja alimentamos 10 por cento
do planeta inteiro nosso país é
fundamental na produção de grãos e na
pecuária Além disso nos últimos 10 anos
no mercado mundial de alimentos o Brasil
deu um salto com sua participação de
20,6 bilhões para 100 Bilhões de Dólares
nosso território o solo é tão fértil que
é possível plantar Praticamente tudo que
se deseja desde frutas grãos cereais
raízes e até cultura de florestamento
São plantadas nos solos brasileiros
realmente no mundo não existe país mais
fértil que o Brasil
O porém mesmo Com todas essas
atribuições e números expressivos o
Brasil está em terceiro lugar entre os
países produtores agropecuários do mundo
o que nos impede de nos tornarmos a
maior potência agrícola
seria falta de espaço para o plantio já
que os dois países mais produtores
possuem território mais e tem esse que
nós Além disso nós temos a floresta
amazônica certo que ocupa quarenta e
dois por cento do nosso território
Realmente pensando assim o problema pode
ser a falta de espaço e isso é o que
muitas pessoas pensam Principalmente as
que moram perto de áreas com florestas
nativas que a área que essas florestas
ocupam podemos ser melhor aproveitadas
com o plantio de diversas culturas e que
a preservação das matas EA produção de
alimentos ou seja agricultura são
assuntos que não possuem relação e
acabam agindo a partir desse pensamento
desmatando para fazer um acesso sua casa
para criar áreas de pastagens para
aumentar o espaço do seu terreno e se
proteger contra animais selvagens ou
simplesmente para exploração do solo
local acreditando que essas e outras
atitudes são irrelevantes para natureza
é mas na verdade que impede o Brasil de
subir nessa colocação entre os países
produtores agropecuários tá muito além
da simples falta de espaço atualmente
nós temos grandes centros de
desenvolvimento de sementes que geram
plantas como a maior produtividade
além de maquinários que otimizam os
processos de plantio e colheita
desse modo nós conseguimos o melhor
aproveitamento do solo por hectare
plantado com grãos e plantas de melhor
qualidade e processos de plantio e
colheita que viabiliza um produto mais
fresco
sendo assim nós diminuímos as
necessidades de desmatamentos Ilegais
para a criação de novas áreas de plantio
e o nosso país como acabei de dizer tem
um problema que tá muito lindo assim que
falta de espaço e ele tá depois do
plantio o problema do Brasil tá no
escoamento da produção e na estocagem
adequada
nosso país produz safras recordes de
grãos por intenso uma defasagem cílios
adequados para estocagem dos mesmos bem
como o condições adequadas para o
escoamento da produção como estradas em
más condições linhas férreas de duas
vias escassas e sem investimentos e
alguns portos pouco desenvolvidos o que
faz com que as Produções do interior
território tem que se deslocar durante
caminhos mais longos até porta de
qualidade para que exportação possa ser
feita de forma adequada isso faz com que
os produtores tenham mais gastos já em
menos lucros e o país também segue menos
com as divisas da exportação
e agora que nós já sabemos o impecilho
do Brasil para se tornar a maior
potência Agrícola no mundo vamos voltar
o que realmente penso que é um problema
que é ocupação de grandes áreas por
florestas nativas pensando dessa forma e
se a gente desmatar grande parte dessas
áreas para simplesmente transformar elas
em plantações ou em área de pastagens
essa na verdade não é pergunta é muitas
vezes a ação que essas pessoas tomam sem
sequer imaginar quantidade de
consequências que elas poderiam causar
ao meio ambiente
é a principal delas e que todos nós já
ouvimos é que eu vi um aquecimento
global daqui alguns anos e ele causa uma
drástica diminuição da fauna e da flora
são todas verdades Mas vamos concordar
que apesar de serem extremamente
importantes e já serem uma realidade
nosso dia a dia infelizmente Essas são
consequências que não chamam mais
atenção da maioria das pessoas já estão
saturadas a mente da maioria delas
por isso agora eu trago aqui algumas
consequências que você provavelmente
nunca ouviu sobre o mundo sem Amazônia
o segundo o INPE que é o Instituto
Nacional de Pesquisas espaciais se sem
por cento da floresta for destruída até
o ano de 2050 nós teremos uma diminuição
de 25 por cento das chuvas Isso
acarretaria numa diminuição do fluxo dos
rios podendo gerar longos períodos de
seca comprometendo noventa porcento das
plantações brasileiras já que somente 10
por cento delas possuem ligação
E além disso o baixo fluxo dos rios
também poderia comprometer a produção de
energia no Brasil que é majoritariamente
hidrelétrica
e a qualidade do solo e o curso dos rios
também poderão ser afetados já que a
cobertura vegetal garante a qualidade da
terra e impede o assoreamento dos rios
polinizadores e outros animais também
poderão ser afetados podendo causar a
extinção de diversas espécies que não só
possuímos aqui nessa parte do mundo
o devido ao seu tamanho a floresta
amazônica ela também é responsável por
grande parte da umidade e das chuvas que
caem em praticamente todo o território
sul-americano por meio dos rios voadores
que são grandes massas de ar com muito
vapor da água que vem do Oceano caem em
forma de chuva na floresta e lá as
árvores por meio da evapotranspiração
geram novamente grandes massagear com
muita umidade que percorre pela
Praticamente todo o território
brasileiro e os outros países
sul-americanos
esses Rios possui uma vazão superior ao
maior rio do mundo o Rio Amazonas eles
irrigam principalmente no nosso país a
região centro-oeste que a mais plantada
do território
em outro estudo que comprova a gravidade
desse problema é o efeitos do
desmatamento Tropical no clima e na
agricultura da cientistas Débora
Lawrence e Karen Van de carne elas
afirmam que quando o desmatamento na
Amazônia atingir quarenta por cento do
seu território que atualmente já está em
a admissão da chuva seguia sentido a
mais de 3,2 mil km de distância ou seja
na bacia do rio Prata que fica no
extremo sul do continente sul-americano
e
com admissão dessas grandes massas de
chuva nós temos podemos concluir com
certeza que haveria uma quebra do
sistema de agricultura no Brasil e de
pecuária também que ao considerar
alimentos consumidos aqui atualmente
setenta por cento deles vem da
Agricultura ou da pecuária familiar
e isso nos leva até economia que 21,6
por cento do PIB brasileiro corresponde
atualmente ao agronegócio
a todos esses fatores acreditar em uma
quebra do sistema de agricultura e
pecuária em nosso país e prejudicaria
fortemente a nossa economia e o
suprimento de alimento no mundo em razão
da grandiosidade do Brasil nesse assunto
e Aqui nós temos um gráfico da
secretaria especial de agricultura que
mostra a porcentagem de cada alimento
que a consumida no Brasil que vem da
Agricultura ou da pecuária familiar
vamos conversar pelo topo nas carnes de
origem animal a suína por exemplo
representa 59 por cento ou seja de toda
a carne suína que a consumida no Brasil
atualmente
59 delas tem por cento delas tem
procedência da pecuária familiar
e em seguida um pouco abaixo nós temos o
feijão tradicional na dieta brasileira
ele não poderia deixar de ser citado
aqui de todo o feijão que é consumido no
Brasil atualmente
setenta por cento dele vem da
Agricultura Familiar
e em seguida nós temos os produtos da
horticultura como couve alface
cenoura beterraba em média esses
produtos representam 63 por cento de
participação ou seja de todos os
produtos consumidos 63 por cento deles
vem da Agricultura Familiar também
e em seguida e por fim nós temos os
produtos mais específicos com a mandioca
por exemplo que tem incríveis
87 por cento de procedência da
agricultura familiar em nosso país
bom e é por isso que eu trouxe aqui hoje
a preservação da Amazônia junto com
alimentação para concientizar as pessoas
de uma forma diferente que o pedaço de
carne no seu prato a mandioca o feijão a
beterraba a cenoura
alface o leite ou melhor centenas de
alimentos que você não se você tem no
seu prato hoje podem simplesmente sumir
os tornarem muito difícil de ser
adquiridos citamos não lutaremos para
nossa Floresta
é através de estudos nós podemos afirmar
que as condições de biomas preservados
Associados áreas de cultivo trazem uma
maior produtividade Neste contexto
consegue-se garantir um equilíbrio
natural preservando polinizadores cursos
de rios e propriedades dos solos por
outro lado uma agricultura sustentável é
fundamental para o desenvolvimento
humano o planeta está em constante
crescimento e vai precisar de cada vez
mais comida de qualidade para suprir as
necessidades da população
e a preservação da Amazônia ela não se
deve somente pela fauna e pela forma
presente nela mas sim porque ela exerce
um papel extremamente importante na
nossa sobrevivência e no nosso bem-estar
as políticas de preservação não devem
ser encaradas de forma de instante
independente
abordagem dessas políticas devem levar
em conta o desenvolvimento da sociedade
aliada a conservação dos recursos
naturais
por fim encontrar um caminho onde a
natureza EA agricultura possam coexistir
vai ser fundamental para o
desenvolvimento de uma nação e
consequentemente da humanidade diante de
todas essas reflexões e esses
acontecimentos eu faço a pergunta vocês
vamos iniciar vamos trazer de volta
todos esses assuntos que são
extremamente importantes nosso dia-a-dia
mas não tem a devida importância que nós
não damos a devida importância a eles
obrigado
E aí
[Música]